Anie Samson et Luc Ferrandez
bonsoir.
Du mouvement aujourd'hui.
- C'est le cas de le dire.
Mouvement Montréal.
- Balarama Holness, les gens
voient cette affiche un peu
partout en ville. Ils ont mis de
l'argent. Je vous montre pour
qu'on saisisse un peu les
conséquences de ce mouvement, je
vous montre un sondage léger.
Tout cela bouge. Il est à 8 %.
Si on les additionne, cela fait
13 avec Desjardins. Ça donne un
peu un ordre de grandeur.
Qu'est-ce que vous dépensez
Annie?
- Je salue la maturité de
Desjardins d'avoir eu cet esprit
avec Balarama Holness de dire :
si on veut vraiment se présenter
pour Montréal, et si on veut
faire la différence, c'est sûr
que deux partis différents
gagneraient pas. Ils se sont
dits : ensemble, on a peut-être
plus de chance de faire héler
encore plus de candidats et de
se faire connaître. Et quitter
un parti, je l'ai vu dans mon
parti. C'est déjà arrivé.
Ce n'est pas évident. Surtout
pour Desjardins qui achève.
Grâce à GAN : je pense que le
bateau va bien mais peut aller
plus vite avec le bateau du
voisin d'à côté. Ils sont
vraiment en train...
- va bien...
- tranquillement.
Avec Balarama Holness, l'équipe
était plus organisée et en plus
de moyens. C'est un choix
difficile. Ça n'a pas été un
choix facile. Marc-Antoine...
- Il faut mettre l'ego de côté.
- Oui.
- Le trigone
- la première promesse. Balarama
Holness faire une ville
bilingue. Il voulait aller
contre le statut de ville
d'abord française de statut de
langue française de Montréal.
Marc-Antoine Desjardins voulait
en faire une perle de la
francophonie. Ils étaient très
loin. Ils sont à l'opposé.
Ce qui les rassemble, c'est les
points habituels. Un meilleur
service à la population, moins
de bureaucratie etc. C'est ce
que tout le monde ici. Aussi, je
pense que ces deux personnes ne
sont pas prêts ni l'un ni
l'autre être mère. Je les aime
beaucoup. Cet immense bonhomme
sympathique, Desjardins, quand
Valérie Plante a été candidate à
la mairie, ça faisait quatre ans
qu'elle posait des questions
d'une demi-heure à chaque
personne qu'elle rencontrait
pendant quatre ans.
Ces personnes ne sont pas
passées par ça. Ils ne sont pas
prêts. Plusieurs de leurs
déclarations qui démontrent
qu'ils n'ont pas tout à fait
compris ce que c'était des
pouvoirs de la ville que le
budget de la ville. Deux garçons
- ils n'ont pas fait leur
devoir.
- Ce serait excellent personne
pour devenir d'abord conseiller,
apprendre le métier, apprendre
les lois et les règlements et
les budgets et un jour se
présente à la mairie. Il passe
tout à l'État parce qu'il
considère comme les montréalais
qu'elle n'a pas traînés pour
plante est née pour Denis
Coderre. Cela prend une
troisième fois ça va être moi.
Je pense que c'est prématuré.
- Est-ce que cela nuit plus à M.
Coderre ou Mme Plante?
- Je mets en désaccord avec Luc
parce que lorsqu'on a été la
première fois, on n'avait jamais
fait de politique ni Luc ni moi.
On n'avait pas de guide.
- Et n'était pas la mère. Il
était le roi Du Plateau.
- Dans ce cas, ce que ça prouve,
ce qu'il va aller chercher des
gens qui ne veulent ni voter
pour Denis Coderre ni voter pour
Valérie Plante. Elle donne une
chance au lieu de se diviser en
deux dire : écoutez venez chez
nous et ont peut-être des
excellents conseillers dans
l'opposition. Comme projet
Montréal a fait la première fois
avec Richard Bergeron.
Il a été élu dans l'opposition.
Il était le seul dans
l'opposition la première fois de
représenter projet Montréal.
Aujourd'hui projet Montréal et
au pouvoir. Il faut commencer
quelque part ils peuvent avoir
des ambitions mais si les
ambitions font héler une dizaine
de conseillers tant mieux.
- Je rappelle la question.
ça nuit le plus?
- Mme Plante parce qu'elle a des
idées plus environnementalistes.
C'est difficile parce que ceux
qui ne veulent pas voter Denis
ne va pas nécessairement voter
Valérie Plante. Ce qui ne va pas
Valérie Plante Néron pas chez
Denis Coderre.
- Effectivement ces deux
électorats bien distincts.
Ce que Denis Coderre voulait
avoir ça va de l'opposition.
Tous les gens qui ne sont pas
satisfaire de Mme Plante.
Donc, des gens qui disent qu'ils
ne veulent pas voter pour Mme
Plante mais ne veulent pas voter
pour Monsieur Coderre. Ils vont
voter pour la troisième fois.
Peu de gens qui vont voter pour
eux auraient voté pour Mme
Plante. Ils n'en veulent place
de Mme Plante.
- Je pourrais rajouter quelque
chose. Au niveau de la clientèle
si on regarde les gens la
clientèle jeune va beaucoup
aller vers Valérie Plante. Les
deux candidats vont chercher des
candidats qui sont aussi jeunes.
Cette voie va aller quelque
part. Rappelez-vous que l'âge
moyen à Montréal c'est 38 ans.
Selon les statistiques 2016 et
2021. Cette clientèle jeune va
plus se retrouver dans ces
programmes.
- Ça peut nuire à Mme Plante. Le
vote plus jeune. La diversité et
tout. Très bien. Est-ce qu'on a
le temps d'écouter un petit
extrait d'hier?
Débat sur la situation
internationale.
Monsieur Coderre dit qu'il
connaît beaucoup de monde.
DENIS CODERRE, candidat, mairie
de Montréal, chef, Ensemble Mtl.
- C'est pas qui tu es, c'est qui
tu connaîs. Avec ma bonne amie
Anne Hidalgo...
Comme Ban Ki-moon notre ami
nous disait...
Avec Monsieur Hollande et
les autres notamment, avec Mike
Bloomberg lorsqu'on a créé
Compact of Mayor.
- Non, moi je ne commencerai
pas à parler au "je" puis faire
du name dropping pour me donner
de l'importance. Je ne me valide
pas en fonction des gens à qui
je parle et encore moins que
je le dis devant les gens pour
dire : "Regardez comment je suis
big, regardez comment je suis
important".
- Quand je disais que c'est
tendu, encore. Luc, Monsieur
Coderre dit qu'il connaît
beaucoup de monde. Cela fait 40
ans que je fais de la politique.
Qu'avez-vous pensé de ça?
- Ça peut servir. Monsieur Kolar
s'était beaucoup impliquée pour
avoir une ligne directe avec
Shanghai en jouant avec les
acteurs locaux, en poussant sur
les acteurs locaux pour qu'il
travaillait avant cette ligne.
Je pense que c'est cela la
force. - Travailler avec les
gens d'ici pour avoir des
rayonnements. Le rayonnement par
exemple des joueurs de tennis ou
des réalisateurs comme Denis
Villeneuve. C'est ici que ça se
passe. On travaille avec eux
pour que ça rayonne. Cependant
se promener dans le monde, c'est
pas que le maire va se promener
dans le monde. Que ça va changer
les choses.
- Je la comprends. Du name
dropping, c'est toujours
impressionnant. On a un réseau
international, cela aide à faire
des négociations pour certains
dossiers. On l'a vu à l'époque
en 2013, Montréal dans les
journaux internationaux étaient
bannis à cause du scandale de
tout ce qui s'est passé avec
Monsieur Tremblay. En quatre
ans, on a réussi à ramener
Montréal sur la carte
internationale. C'est important
d'avoir ces contacts. Pas juste
les nommer.
- Il n'a pas à le cacher. Une
question de personnalité.
- Il n'a pas se vanté de cela.
On a plus de tem